Hello and welcome to my neuron's, myself.
Not my neurons, of course, and not myself.
I-oh my goodness. Look at all these cells
out here. Look at you. Look at all these cells.
And I suspect that each one of you would probably
say that you are a self just like- or you
claim, at least, that you're as much of a
self as I am. That's my guess anyway. All
these cells. Well. Whatever self means. Whatever
self is. This is this is making me perhaps
self conscious. And you maybe too. And whatever
self means and whatever conscious means, much
less consciousness means. Whatever "means"
means. It's so hard to describe these things.
So therefore, before we start, a couple of
basics about our time our title: My Neurons,
Myself. A neuron, it turns out, is not only
a brain cell, as many of us had thought until
we looked it up. But a nerve cell anywhere
in the body, arms, legs, the spine, that is
somehow linked to the 86 billion neurons that
are packed into the brain. That's the latest
close estimate. 86 billion neurons packed
into the brain inside the skull. And the neural
network, which links up those cells in the
brain, is astonishingly similar as you can
see here to the recently discovered networks
of billions of galaxies, which are the latest
discovery by the astronomers and physicists,
of the overall structure of the universe.
The galaxies seem to line up in the same kind
of filigree network that are-brain cells and
their connections seem to. And there are already
some serious articles in scientific journals
that suggest this may not be a coincidence,
but possibly they're exploring whether it
shows a common pattern of forces shaping things
great and small galaxies-like neurons so to
speak. But this is new information. And of
course, there's an enormous amount of skepticism
coming from all angles about whether that
is a coincidence or not. Whether we are just
each a proton in the brain of some oaf sitting
under another tree.
Dr. Seuss has been there in a lot of other
thinkers as well. Who knows. Secondly, a quick
word about the nature of words themselves.
We want to get every detail in. The nature
of words themselves, especially the words
that may have attracted you to this program,
such as neurons, self, memory. What is memory?
Soul, soul. You must have thought about that
emotion. Mind. What is the mind? Consciousness.
Scientists and philosophers have been pointing
out for a long time that just because we've
got a word for something doesn't necessarily
mean there's anything there, including self,
consciousness, for example. We may feel we
know what the word means and use it freely
and even use it very well. But, it doesn't
necessarily mean that there's anything there.
But each word has been evolving in its usage
for centuries and our human ability to constantly
change and create their meanings. Well we
have to keep that in mind, so to speak. We
have to constantly remind our- so to speak,
we have to remind ourselves about the fact
that words themselves don't necessarily tell
us about something that's there. As our panelists
use words here, this evening, and gestures,
and emotions, probably to try to enlighten
us. So, to put this all into perspective,
though it may give us a headache or blow our
minds at some point, so to speak. I wonder
what that means? Some of these neuroanatomist
may have ideas about that. To put this into
perspective, we spoke to Dr. George Makari
who directs the Institute for the History
of Psychiatry for the past 20 years at least,
while at Cornell. He points out that we often
tend to think of the mind as a natural, even
a biological, part of who we are. But, he
says this is actually a relatively modern
concept. He has written a book about the history
of these words and ideas and about how the
rise of brain science in recent days and recent
centuries has helped the modern world to emerge
from the old medieval world. Let's take a
look.
In the medieval world, there were two things.
Body and Soul. The soul was the knot of the
universe, because it integrated belief in
God, cosmology, life on Earth, psychology,
the difference in life and death. All those
things. That started to crack with the scientific
revolution. The world started to change. Historian
and psychiatrist George Makari's new book
is called Soul Machine: The Invention of the
Modern Mind. The third entity, the mind, started
to emerge as a natural alternative for the
place for inner life. In the 1500's, notions
of a secular mind were already lurking. Johann
Weyer of Holland dared to suggest to the Church
Fathers that not all witches should be burned
at the stake, because some of them might not
have made covenant with the devil ,but just
be suffering from a disease that crippled
their reasoning. In the 1600s, Oxford Medical
Doctor, Thomas Willis, began dissecting and
mapping the brain, launching modern neuroscience
in the West. And his most famous student,
philosopher John Locke, developed a science-
based theory of mind and of self that said
they were based partly on imperfect, subjective
impressions. The mind was highly scandalous,
very dangerous as an idea, and was one that
very much had a lot of political and scientific,
medical and theological implications that
made it quite explosive. Why? It challenged
absolutism, both in terms of political power
and in terms of clerical power. The mind was
fallible. It could not make absolute claims
about truth. It demanded, therefore, tolerance.
Because if I can't know the absolute truth,
I should tolerate you and you should tolerate
me. It allowed for secular ethics like life,
liberty, and the pursuit of happiness.
The idea of a center of reason and will that
was not immortal caught on and, says Makari,
helped change the way the West was run. It's
the centerpiece of the emergence of secular
culture. But there was a problem. Could you
locate this new sort of mind in the brain?
Well the brain is easy to define. I mean,
you could make the cut where you want, but
the brain is an empirical object. The problem
is interior experience and mind is not like
any other object in the natural world. Because
it's not available to the external observer
and always available to us. Today, we have
technologies that can amaze us with new discoveries
of how some parts of the brain work and are
connected. What we don't have yet, I would
argue, is a way of bridging mental experience
with the brain in a coherent model that allows
for mental intention. And so, I would say
we still are a ways off from solving the mind-
brain problem. Evolving concepts of mind and
self, spurred by scientific explorations,
have helped to change how societies are governed.
Basing our hopes more on the real world. The
exciting question now is whether our dazzling
new technology can help us understand what
we're really talking about when we speak of
the mind, the self, and even perhaps, the
soul.
Dr. George Makari is in the audience tonight.
If you have questions afterwards, he and some
of our other panelists will be able to stay
around and talk in the in the in the lobby
afterwards. So let's get down to business.
Tonight, we're going to be talking with four
scientists and philosophers all, in one way
or another, working on the cutting edge of
neuroscience, of psychology, and philosophy
to help us understand some of the latest thinking
on the self and consciousness. Our first participant
is a neuroscientist and the head of Yale's
Brain Function laboratory. One of the early
adopters of functional magnetic resonance
imaging, she is now pioneering the use of
near infrared spectroscopy to study the brains
of two humans as they interact. Please welcome
Joy Hirsch. Oh, no, no, that's my chair, actually.
We're working out our neural connections.
Our next guest is a neuroscientist and professor
in the Department of Psychology at the Zuckerman
Mind, Brain, Behavior Institute at Columbia
University. Her work has yielded insights
into how the brain changes with learning,
how memories are created and retrieved, and
how memory shapes our decisions, our actions,
and our selves. Please welcome Daphna Shohamy.
Also joining us, is a neuro-ethicist at the
University of Pennsylvania. A former Guggenheim
fellow and recipient of the Association for
Psychological Sciences Lifetime Achievement
award. She's currently studying the way neuroscience
is changing how we think of ourselves as physical,
mental, and moral beings. Please welcome Martha
Farah. And our fourth participant is a philosopher
from the City University of New York and a
leader in the growing field of experimental
philosophy, which brings empirical methods
to bear on philosophical questions. He's the
author of several books including Furnishing
the Mind, Gut Reactions, and The Emotional
Construction of Morals. Please welcome Jesse
Prinz.
So let's take a look at how one new technology
is advancing our understanding of the brain
and helping us to look for new ways to approach
consciousness. In your work Joy, you're asking
whether there is a neurobiology of collective
consciousness- consciousness. Tell us what
your experiments aim to do.
So just to start with, the last three decades
of neuroscience, particularly systems neuroscience,
where we try to understand the workings of
the brain by putting people in scanners and
watching the brain respond, has really been
dominated by techniques like functional magnetic
resonance imaging for example and these are
wonderful technologies that taught us a great
deal about principles of neural organization.
But the one really important function that
we never can connect with, or understand with
this technology, is the most important function
I think of all of us as humans, and that is
how we connect to each other. So that we are
social beings, looking and talking to each
other, are never studied in the conventional
magnetic resonance imaging or imaging techniques
that that we have available to us. So one
of the frontiers that's been lurking for a
long time, has been the frontier of how in
the world are we going to understand what
goes on in the human brain when two people
are in front of each other looking at each,
other talking to each other, and interacting
in a social way. So. Enter a new technology.
And this new technologies- see, I'll get to
your question in a minute- this new technology
allows us to put what we call up, optodes,
on people's heads. We don't have to put people
in the scanner and we can actually use reflectance.
Do you want to explain what this is? Is that
going to be your next question?
Well, light goes in, right?
Yes. OK. I'm glad you asked that question.
Because I don't-
This is not fMRI, but the next stage.
Oh, okay, there's a picture here. OK this
is terrific. So these are two people that
are set up in the near- infrared spectroscopy
situation. Now, you can see they have these
little things on their heads. We call them
optodes. And what a little optode is, is a
little laser emitter. So it emits a wavelength
of light. You know if you take a flashlight,
you just shine it in your finger and you kind
of see it diffused through your through your
finger. It's the same principle as that. Just
a little wavelength of light that goes into
the brain. And from that, we can infer what's
going on in the brain.
So this light goes through the skull.
It goes through the skull. And let me just
divert here and just tell you one principle.
In order to understand this, you need- need
that you only need to understand one thing
about how the brain works. And that is, that
when active neural tissue is involved, like
say your visual system is working, it's active
neural tissue. When that happens, your brain
is recruiting blood to that locally active
area and that blood is highly oxygenated.
As it turns out, that change in oxygenation
is the signal that we use in fMRI, which is
the traditional imaging technology. It is
also it is also the basis for the signal that
we use in near-infrared spectroscopy. So,
we shine a little light into the brain that
it goes all the way through the skull, it
goes down about three centimeters. And then
it bounces back up and when it bounces back
up, part of it has been absorbed. But what
has been absorbed depends on whether it has
gone through highly oxygenated blood or whether
it has gone through blood that is deoxygenated
or parts of the brain that are not working.
So- so sorry go ahead.
No go ahead.
So you're looking at brains while people are,
two brains, when people are talking to each
other.
That's exactly right. So now, we're free from
the scanner and we can actually put people
in front of each other and put these lasers,
like little swim caps, on their heads and
have them talking, interrelating, looking
at each other. And we have a whole new neuroscience
in front of us and this is the neuroscience
that aims to understand activity of the human
brain when we're actually interacting in real
time, in natural situations, we're behaving
in ways that connect us, not just ourselves,
but connect us to other people.
So what you find goes on in the brains of
people who are talking to each other?
Well, partially that the- the- the tradition
the traditional work in neuroscience, has
taught us a great deal- oh good- has taught
us a great deal about what we know about how
the language system actually works. We know
we've got tools for Wernicke's area, for reception,
we got tools for production. And these guys
kind of work back and forth in a single brain.
Well, as it turns out just as you might expect,
they work back and forth when they're talking
to each other. And so we can see two brains
when- using Wernicke's area and Broca's area
in ways that are taking turns with each other
as we're communicating.
There's a picture of Wernicke's word comprehension
and Broca's brain speech production. So in
conversation, they would naturally come alive.
They do. They work back and forth. Now that
isn't too surprising. You would expect that
is so. And so, we've used these are these
first level experiments to just to document
our methodologies. You know if you know an
answer to something, as a scientist, it's
a really nice thing to find it, particularly
when you're starting something new. And so
we've used these talking back and forth experiments
to document what we know about the brain already.
And what these measurements, these wavelengths,
actually show. Do they line up or?
Yes. What- what happens-I think there some
other slides there that show what happens
when two brains are actually in in a dialogue
with each other. You have to remember that-
the our two brains are a little bit like cell
phones, because what we're doing is sending
and receiving wireless communications. So
we're talking to each other, we're looking
at each other. So you can think of two people
as kind of as kind of cell phones. And you
think what is- what are those signals that
are going back and forth across people? Well
there's the sound signals, there are the visual
signals, and so on. And you watch the machinery
of the two brains actually receiving and sending
and receiving and sending. Just very much
like the original. Yeah that's interesting.
That's an interesting picture- sending and
receiving like you would expect a model cell
phone to do. What we learn from these techniques,
I think that was the question you asked, is
that in the case of dialogue when people are
looking at each other, that parts of our brains
are in synchrony with our partner. So if I'm
talking to you, my production area, Broca's
area, is resonating with your Wernicke's area,
your reception area. And when you're talking
to me, it alternates. And so our brains, in
some sense, fuse. They fuse as we become a
unit by talking, by sending and receiving
and sending and receiving.
So forgive me for asking a little bit ahead
here, but that means ourselves. Each of these
two selves become somewhat overlapping. If
our self is involved with what our brain is,
our brain changes when we're talking.
I believe that that's the new idea that comes
from this new opportunity in neuroscience
to study two brains together. Because what
we see, is that partners become a unit. They
become a unit and our brains tend to work
in a partnership. Sharing mode.
Are we looking at a picture of world peace?
I- I wish it were so simple, but I do think
that as we begin to understand the neural
machinery that is involved in interpersonal
interrelationships that we can begin to understand
better the biological nature of conflict and
perhaps this resolution between humans.
I noticed you had face recognition up there
also as something that goes back and forth.
Yeah
I'm thinking about how we can now talk to
Syria and say I'd like to talk face to face
with a friend of mine who's on the other side
of the planet. We are now living increasingly
in something called Web World, so to speak,
where we can in present time communicate throughout
the entire species, the human species. I'm
leaping ahead here, but if you all are beginning
to show us on graphs that our minds get into
sync with each other when we talk, that might
give us hope that we could explain this to
each other that it matters what we say to
each other and you're showing us how we change
when we get angry or get out of sync.
Well that's the hope. I think we have to understand
that these are very early days with this new
technology. Turns out, the technology has
been around for quite a while, but it hasn't
been used in this application. So we're just
beginning as scientists to understand how
to use this new tool. It's a little bit like
15 years ago or so when functional MRI was
relatively new. We didn't quite know how to
use it. And so, it is the hope that we can
open some many new doors in neuroscience to
directly answer some of these questions. How
do we- how do our brains work differently
when we're working together? Whether we're
face to face or whether we're on some media
on the other side of the planet
Or how does television affect us? Or when
we identify with a movie star? Or- or when
advertising affects us? Or-this is a family
show so when you haven't yet figured out how
to get Masters and Johnson involved here yet,
I suppose, but more intimate- I mean or between
people. I mean the mind is blowing my mind,
so to speak. The- the idea you could eventually
have these two people connected who are on
different sides of the planet talking to each
other on a cell phone on Skype.
It's really interesting. I had a summer student
last summer who wanted to know how our brains
differed when they were talking face to face
and whether they were- when they were texting
each other. And I started this with the notion
that, oh texting really didn't involve much
of the social brain. And what we're going
to see is this active social areas of the
brain when we're face to face, but we're not
going to see very much in texting. Well I
was plenty wrong. As often times, students
show the professors are wrong and this was
one of them. The texting actually involved
a lot more what we call the temporal parietal
junction, that's a sweet spot in the brain
that we think is sensitive to social interactions.
So it turns out, that in all the people that
were texting each other, they were involving
this very special part of the brain. And we
interpreted this as a greater involvement
of theory of mind, ways of projecting yourself
into another person. But anyway, so the moral
is, we don't really know very much about what
goes on the brain the social interactions
and we have an awful lot to learn.
But you've opened the door here
We've opened the door. And that's what is
really exciting. It's very humbling. As a
scientist, it's very humbling to start at
the very beginning of kind of a new area.
Your hypothesis was basically proved would
be something they're looked at.
That's right.
Dr. Farah, how does this change your understanding
of consciousness? Why were you so surprised?
I always do that when somebody says the word
"consciousness." Well let- let me let me let
me answer a similar question, not exactly
that, if I may. Which is, you know, how does
how does it change the way I think about,
you know, sort of how people think about people,
how people think about the message that they're
trying to convey to somebody else, and whether
or not that somebody else has received it.
Those kinds of issues which I'm sure consciousness
plays a role in there. But it is- I think
we can figure out a lot about the kinds of
things that Joy is studying and the kinds
of things that make us human. Right? You know
we- a simple conversation actually involves
all kinds of processing of not only what's
on your mind, but what you think the listener
already knows, needs to hear to have what
you're saying to her be clear. So that back
and forth is-, I mean yes it involves the
sort of nuts and bolts of the language system,
Wernicke's area, Broca's area, auditory etc.
But as- as Joy, was just mentioning towards
the end, so much more all the social areas.
Our brain has a ton of hardware, you know,
neural wetware that's dedicated to just representing
people's selves our own selves, other selves,
the temporal parietal junction that she mentioned
is specialized for thinking about what is
on somebody else's mind, and what they're
trying to do, and where they're going et cetera
et cetera. My TPJ is just noticing little
finger raised, which tells me Bill wants to
ask follow up, change the direction. That's
my TPJ. So it's- it's part of communication,
but it was language per se.
What was that acronym again?
TPJ. Temporoparietal junction.
And that's going-
Yeah, that's pretty- pretty good anatomy,
yeah. You know, the temporal lobes are the
kind of long sausage-y things on the side.
Oh, yes, yes, right. So, to go back for a
moment to the slippery concept of consciousness
that made you sit up. I've heard some people
say that consciousness is basically "awareness"
whatever- we're using words to try to get
into this concept her. But Dr. Prinz, what's
the difference between awareness and attention,
for example?
Well I think they're actually the same. I
mean one of the things that we've- I think
been able to do with the science of consciousness
is start to relate this very ethereal concept,
consciousness, awareness, experience to things
that we understand much better. How does consciousness
relate to memory? How does it relate to attention?
Those are questions that we can ask scientifically
and even- even if we never get a full handle
on how a physical thing like the brain can
give rise to experience, we can understand
what processes in the brain are taking place
when we are conscious. And doing that, we
can learn a lot of things about consciousness
that are very important. So suppose we're
using Joy's new technology on somebody who's
watching a magic show and there's this sleight
of hand. So a very good magician might ,you
know, pull- pull a card out of thin air. And
how do they do this? Well of course, the card
was somewhere and if they had a camera trained
on the sleeve or wherever it was located,
it would be very easy to consciously experience
its original location. But a good magician
is going to distract. A good magician might
use hand gestures or even voice to get the
viewer to miss out on the trick. I think conversation
is like that in general. When we're having
a conversation, we're directing each other's
attention and there are many things we might
be attending to. Might be attending to the
emotional expression of our conversation partner
we might be attending to to ourselves. How
do we sound? How are we self presenting? We
might be attending to social hierarchy. Is
this somebody who has a higher status?
Neuroscientists, psychologists studying conversation
very rarely study attention. They very rarely
study power. They very rarely study social
dynamics. They rarely study things like compassion
or aggression or impatience. So conversation
isn't just a string of words, it's a it's
a kind of a multiple channels of information
that are directing what people notice and
what they tend to. The conscious experience
you have, what you notice, the content you
take away, is not just enumerated in the words
that are presented to you, but in all of these
other cues that are telling you what the meaning
is.
So- and consciousness is...?
So attention is, I think, something that allows
information to flow in the nervous system.
When you're having a perceptual encounter
with the world, a lot of what gets in gets
in subliminally. We're totally unaware of
it. You can measure this you can show that
if you present something very quickly say
for 17 milliseconds, followed by a mask- people
have no capacity to experience it whatsoever.
As a journalist, I noticed-I asked you- so
consciousness is? And you very suddenly said
attention. So attention is this?
So attention is the difference between something
getting stuck in your perceptual systems and
sort of hanging out there indefinitely and
passing forward to other parts of the nervous
system where you can think about it, use it
in reasoning, use it in deliberation. Consciousness
is attention and attention is this doorway
that opens that allows perception to access
the rest of
Consciousness is attention and this all sounds
very logical-
Can I disagree?
Yes, yes please.
I mean, so I would say attention is maybe
necessary for consciousness. But, you know,
I don't get the heebie jeebies when people
talk about attention. That's a good mainstream
cognitive neuroscience concept. The- but consciousness
means in these kinds of discussions, that
subjective sense of what something feels like.
How do we know-I
know that I'm paying attention? Is there a
subject- usually subjective?
So you know Ned Block, a colleague of yours.
Yes at NYU philosophy, distinguishes between
consciousness of A for access. Or you could
say attention too, that is consciousness in
the sense that we can access some information,
we can access that somebody looked surprised
by what we've just said, or you know whatever,
and consciousness of P for phenomenal or phenomenology.
Right? That kind of feeling of what it's like
to be experiencing that. And I think whenever
we're talking about subjective mental states,
phenomenological mental states, I think that's-
that's when I do jump when people hit me with
"consciousness." you know, when I'm not expecting
it
It's spooky.
It is spooky. I think we are profoundly ignorant
and probably always will be about how you
get that subjectivity out of it.
I've been thinking about this problem before,
I felt a great relief when I heard there was
a philosopher named Thomas Nagel who solves
the problem. He said consciousness is simply
one of the irreducible of the universe, is
just there like gravity and mass and various
creatures tap into it and reconstruct it in
various ways. So
This to me, is a few-Tom Nagel was a teacher
of mine. He brought me to this subject and
I'm very much in his debt. Ned is a colleague,
Ned Block and we've talked together and work
together on various things. I think there's
a way in which we get ourselves into this
air of mystery. It's needless. And it creates
problems that aren't really there. When people
used to talk about life, they were absolutely
mystified how life could figure in the physical
world. And when things like the structure
of DNA were discovered, it was a major intellectual
breakthrough because suddenly this thing that
seemed absolutely mystified, absolutely impossible
to explain, was understood in physical terms.
Descartes thought the big mystery of the mind
was not conscious experience but reason. Descartes,
maybe one of the greatest minds in the history
of Western thought, could not figure out how
reason could be physically explained. Then
computers came along and we have a program.
That in a very simple way, is doing complex
derivations of mathematical proofs. That's
reasoning. So I think we're going to get to
a point with consciousness where once we found
out what are the psychological processes and
the neurobiological processes that take place
that make the difference between seeing something
and not. Then we're going to be in a position
to say that some of this sort of wallowing
in mystery was really unnecessary. And other
very exciting questions can be answered.
Well, I know that you're nodding and so maybe
you get- let's say you're half agreeing with
him maybe? But let me ask Daphna. We'll come
back. So Daphna.
I just, I guess I think I wanted to back Martha
up. It's not just that it's difficult to define
and maybe lose, maybe in that sense I'm backing
both of you up, but I think one of the important
discoveries from psychology and neuroscience
over the past decade or two, is not just that
it's hard to define semantically and phenomenology,
but then actually it's not as required or
central as we thought it is. Whether you find
it as awareness or even attention or consciousness.
What's not as required?
A consciousness that a lot of things we thought
required conscious awareness actually don't.
And my perspective on that comes from research
on memory.
I was going to ask you- to get back to our
title, Neurons and Self. How does memory define
the self and what you're- you were just about
to go there, I guess.
I was, I will. What I was going to say is
that you know if we think about memory in
many ways, in the most kind of mundane ways.
So if I ask everyone here if they remember
where they were when they bought their tickets
to this show or received their tickets to
this show. We can actually now- you're thinking
about it. You can bring back that memory and
that in of itself is an interesting process
that we can understand in neurobiological
terms. So you brought it to conscious awareness,
because I asked you to. But that's really
just one way in which we remember that results
in some kind of conscious awareness or attention.
But we know that those kind of memories influence
our behaviors all the time without having
brought them to mind in any conscious way.
So it's something that we used to think that
consciousness is an incredibly central feature
of memory retrieval and we now know that those
same neurons that allow you to create and
retrieve memories are actually also supporting
a whole host of behaviors that are not consciously
aware that are related to memory. But we have
to kind of redefine what we mean by what a
memory is.
You mean, it's doing a lot of thinking without
us- asking our permission and without us being
in charge?
Yes I think that's the good news and the bad
news.
So. So how do memories contribute to the sense
of self? How do they get connected?
It's a it's- it's- it's a great question right.
I mean in many ways what we're trying to understand
is if I ask every person in this room in one
week what they remember from this event tonight.
Most of us will remember very little, that
we know for sure. But probably what we do
remember will be very different. My memory
of tonight will be different from your memory
of tonight would be different their memory
of tonight individually, and I think that's
sort of interesting, because the reason for
that difference has to do with our expectations,
our interests, our motivations, so I think
things that I would think of as a kind of
representing ourselves. So who we are is a
filter on what we meant- what we remember,
the memories we create, but that filter doesn't
come out of nowhere. It itself, I'd say, is
built on memories from what happened before.
And it's this ability to link memories over
a lifetime. And that kind of endless dialogue
between what we expect, what happens, what
gets remembered, and how that shapes our memories.
One of my favorite quotes on this topic is
from Marcel Proust who said, "Remembrance
of things past is not necessarily remembrance
of things as they occurred." Right? So the
idea is that we have biases in our memory.
We change what we remember in subtle and idiosyncratic
personal ways that relate to ourselves
And episodic memory?
Episodic memory is a jargon professional term
in memory research to describe your memory
for an episode. Like when you bought your
tickets or when I was asked to participate
in this. So it's memory for an event in time
and what the picture on the screen is showing
you, are the parts of the brain as identified
and healthy human beings with functional magnetic
resonance imaging, which Joy mentioned. Those
are the parts of the brain that show significant
activity associated with the creation and
retrieval of these sorts of memories.
Creation and retrieval. I mean I've heard
it said that memory is not like a tape recorder.
It's not just feeding back over and over.
Every time you remember something, you're
reconstructing it and never exactly the same
twice.
Well, it doesn't have to not be the same twice,
it can be, but it doesn't- isn't necessarily
the same. And this is where these biases I
think play out. And I think this is where
we start to get to a connection between memory
and self in a more obvious way which is when
if- I did that, you know, I now did a test
on everyone and said, "Remember when you bought
the tickets." By doing that, you're bringing
up a memory and you're bringing it up in this
context and your brain is now linking those
two memories together because it's retrieving
a memory in a new context and kind of recreating
the memory, rewriting the memory.
You're beginning to be able to show some of
this with neuroscience, looking at the brain.
You can see this happening?
To some extent, yes, right? So we are we work
in a lab and these are difficult questions
and so we take these interesting questions,
like what it means to have a self and connect
memories across a lifetime, but we don't put
you in a scanner for your lifetime. Which
we-that would be fun if you ever want to volunteer.
What we do is we create computer games that
simulate this kind of process over the span
of an hour or two or a few days where we have
common elements come up and we can ask- when
common elements come up and experiences you
see on the screen, when we track the retrieval
of the memory and then it's- it's connection
with this new situation that just came up
and so we can kind of track how in that sense
how two memories get networked together, get
linked. And what that means for how we use
memories later on.
And how do, how do memories affect our sense
of the future?
The I think the really interesting discoveries
in memory in recent years is, you know, we
think- coming back to that is that example,
instead of thinking of memory as like just
memory for one event in time in one moment,
it turns out that the same neurons, the same
brain tissue, the same regions of the brain
that we know are absolutely essential for
creating these kind of episodic memories have
a much broader role in behavior. They're essential
for planning and, what we call prospecting,
or imagining events in the future. And that's-
I think a really good hint to the importance
of memory and how essential memory is not
just for a sort of reminiscing about the past,
but for planning. And in a way, it's a more
mundane role. But I think a much more central
one in imagining what will happen when this
program is over, what's going to happen tomorrow,
what decisions should I make about my retirement.
That we use memory and leverage it to make
predictions about the future.
Right. And this slide we have a connectivity
between the hippocampus the striata.
Right. So let me define some of that. It gets
at this point. So the heart of the brain that
is probably most central for creating these
kind of episodic memories that we saw, in
part on the earlier slide, is called the hippocampus.
There are fascinating stories that sort of-
the history of science of how we discovered
that the hippocampus is important for memory.
It's really interesting. It goes back to your
famous patient, H.M. We can maybe come back
to that, explain this. So the hippocampus
is important for those kind of memories. The
striatum is a separate part of the brain,
that for a very long time, we thought was
important for completely different sorts of
behavior. The striatum is the part of the
brain that's disrupted most significantly
in Parkinson's disease, for example, and it's
in charge of kind of planned actions, motivated
actions. So many of us have shown that there
is important crosstalk, correlation, connectivity
between the hippocampus, creating memories
and the striatum, planning actions. And suggests
that there is a way in which memories are
feeding into many of our behaviors, even when
we're not consciously aware of that.
After all, the past doesn't exist in a sense
except in the present tense instant of our
mind. It's gone. You look for is not there.
You go to the Gettysburg and all you find
is McDonald's and so on. We often play it
over as if it was, in our own life.
Right. Right now I think that's exactly right
and in that you know to quote another very
wise man, Daniel Kahneman the economist, once
said, you know, "We make we make most decisions
not based on our experiences, what we think
we're doing, but we make decisions based on
our memory of those experiences." So again
memory is sort of this important filter for-
And you're now able to show that some of the
workings of this dynamic in the brain what
connects, what doesn't connect.
Right. And what this image that you're viewing
now shows you, is kind of another angle on
this story and another reason why we believe
it's very useful and important beyond the
philosophy to, nothing wrong with philosophy,
but that understanding these brain regions,
even though, you know, many of us really just
want to understand just want to understand
how the mind works. But that by understanding
the differences between the behaviors that
these different parts of the brain support,
we hope we can use that to understand disease
better and this is showing for example that
the hippocampus and the striatum differ not
just in, kind of, where they are, you can
see there the hippocampus is in teal and the
striatum is in purple. So they differ in their
support of episodes and inferences for the
hippocampus and habits and kind of actions
for the striatum. But they also are by virtue
of being different structures, play roles
in different kinds of disease. So that is
very helpful for us for using what we hope
are kind of behavioral tests of cognition
and reasoning and behavior to probe the roles
of these areas.
Joy, at this point what Daphna has just said,
do you think it's going to help us narrow
in zero in on what self might be if it does
exist? The concept of self that we're trying
to zero in on?
Well certainly to back Daphna, yes. I mean
the that the notion that we are. That we are
what we remember we are what our experiences.
But -what our experiences contribute to our
sense of well being, certainly yes. And I'm
always thinking about this now and sort of
my new lens of how these- these ideas of self
and who we are- are communicated to another
person. And one of the new ideas that builds
on this, is that we as individuals in the
communication with another, actually engage
in a very active process of sharing. Some
of the recent experiments that we have done
is having people just look at each other.
You ever wonder what happens when you just
look at someone somebody else? That wonderful
glance. Have you ever heard of love at first
sight? It's actually, probably true. That
there is so much that goes on in a look that
we share with another person about ourselves.
So very, very poignant aspect.
Face to face.
I've heard some scientists say that one of
the things that distinguishes our species,
is that we have evolved by far the most expressive
face. Of any species. Is that- that's part
of what you're talking about.
That is exactly what I'm talking about. I
don't know how- if we have the most expressive
face on the planet, but it's a very expressive
one. And what that tells us is that our brains
are very much designed to capture those expressions
and we tell other people about ourselves through
our facial expressions. That's one of the
things that we're seeing with this new study
is how active we are- how active perceptions
are. So that as we look at somebody else,
as we talk with other people, we share who
we are. But we also actively interrogate the
person that we're talking to.
And you can see- you can see in your experiments
how the brain does this.
Yes. Yes. That's that's- that's the goal.
And we do see new levels of specificity for
engagement of that kind.
Fascination. Before we get into philosophy.
Quick question for Martha, what you've heard
so far, I'm watching you nodding and being
fascinated. So why? And does this conversation,
you'd think, add to the potential for understanding
what self might be.
I do. Maybe that's why I am nodding so much.
I also nod to kind of just say I hear you
I hear you. I disagree with you, but I hear
you. But, no. But yeah, you know, I mean,
you know, this actually I'm going to defer
to the philosopher here about this, but my
sense is, in philosophy when people try- when
philosophers try to define what makes a person
the same person over all kinds of changes
from, you know, relaxed because they're just
back from vacation to you know madly finishing
a grant proposal to, you know, you at age
5, you at age 85. That. The- the best account
seems to have something to do with this chaining
of memories, this kind of fabric of memories
and that has really interesting and sad implications
for diseases that impair the formation and
survival of memory, like Alzheimer's, and
I don't know
Exactly. All of this just made me think of-
we- we have an opposite case. We talk about
thinking that people who have dementia or
Alzheimer's lose their sense of self apparently.
And you're all nodding. That that's what seems
to happen is when memories go, self goes.
Or large parts of it, or something like that.
Is that?
I'd like to ask Jesse about that. Yeah, Jesse,
help.
We'll now hear from the empirical philosopher.
John Locke who is mentioned in the introductory
film, wrote a book in 1690 that became the
textbook for the mind for the next 200 years
called An Essay Concerning Human Understanding.
Called? Say that slowly.
An Essay Concerning Human Understanding. In
that book he advances a theory of what a self
is and what makes somebody the same self over
time. And his answer, as it's most usually
interpreted, is memory. Memory is what links
us to our past. So as good students of philosophy,
my collaborators and I assume something like
this was right and we wondered is this really
how ordinary people think? About identity.
And we started to test it. We started to test
it in various ways, but typically using questionnaires.
We ask people about a bunch of traits.
A bunch of?
A bunch of traits- your memories, your cognitive
capacities, your personality, your vocations
in life, your occupation, where you live
And you're not using the word "identity" as
synonymous with self.
We -our interest is in the question, "What
makes somebody the same self? What changes
take place? All of us are changing all the
time. Human beings are radically dynamic.
We are the most capable of learning of any
creature we know and that means we're constantly
just sitting here- every time you hear a sentence,
your brain has been rewired, something is
getting stored, a new trace is there, but
you feel like you're the same person. So part
of understanding what the self is, is understanding
what remains constant such that you can say,
"I'm still me this morning. I'm still the
same person I was this morning. Even though
I've been learning all day." So we wanted
to know what- what matters there and we wanted
to know what our ordinary intuitions about
that. So we asked, "Suppose you lose all of
your memories. Or consider a relative who
is in advanced age and losing memories through-
through neural degeneration. Are they the
same person? And for a question like that,
the answer was usually, "Well they've changed
a little bit, but they're pretty much the
same." And we asked about other capacities,
"What if their personality changes? What if
their interests change." Pretty much the same.
The one thing that really seem to have the
most dramatic impact on identity, according
to our ordinary judgments, is morality. Values.
If your values change, or if you imagine a
relative who suddenly- who spent a life dedicated
to left causes, to voting for Democrats, to
suddenly become a right wing Republican. Right.
That's our that's our response.
OK. This is a very current subject. Yes. How
long before we could avoid mentioning it but.
But first, not to take it for granted. I wanted
to give Father Brown approach to solving things
and not using any terms presuming that we
know what they are. You just talked about
morality and values synonymously. What is
a value? Give us a handy definition.
I think of value as some- some kind of preference
for how people should be or behave. It's a
preference related to or social aspects approach.
So it's better to be like this than that.
That's right.
And the morality is the same?
The judgment of good and bad. This is a better
way to be. This is a worse way to be.
And morality is roughly the sense of-
Morality. I mean some of our values are good
and bad, but other like other demands like
good and bad art or good and bad food. But
morality is about- about the social domain
and the values that we have and morality are
very related to- to reward and punishment.
So when somebody transgress, when they- they
violate our preferences for good and bad we
think they deserve to be punished in some
way. So morality is- is really about regulating
social behavior in a way that concords which
concords with our preference.
All right. So you're talking about identity
political.
So we've measured in a lot of ways. If you
look at political values, there are very often
moral, because policy is direct in behavior.
But religion too is very important for morality.
People have all kinds of values just about
what counts as a good human life. How should
how should we live? Somebody who is not ambitious,
not pursuing goals, not trying to add something
to the universe, might be frowned upon as-
as- as lazy, as a failed human being. So we
have a lot of-anything that involves some
belief about how to live.
Well we're getting into areas that we've got
to get into. They're large, rather large.
Religion of course, causes- is believed to
cause a lot of disagreement. But there's also
been a lot of studies or what they all have
in common. For example, I've seen studies
that show that all the major religions have
some version of the Golden Rule, basic compassion,
don't kill don't kill yourself don't be killed,
can be found in some version or another in
all the major religions, at least in the non
extreme versions of them.
There are certainly overlaps, but I think
it's very important to see the difference.
Because one of the things we do in constructing
itself- when somebody says, "Who are you?"
If we all were the same, if our values were
all the same, that wouldn't be a question
worth asking. So somebody who asked about
your identity is asking, "Which of these slots
do you fall into? Which of these are your
values? What are the things that you really
care about?" And most importantly, behind
that question, you're trying to find out,
"Is this somebody who's like me or somebody
who's different? Is this somebody with whom
I can collaborate, cooperate, form a friendship,
form a romance? Or is it somebody who's so
morally different from me that I can't imagine
relating to them?" When you discover that
a person you've just been having a long conversation
with is voting for the other party. How many
of you who are, say Bernie's supporters, discover
that a close friend supports Hillary and had
this jarring moment where you really wonder
can I be friends with this person anymore?
We won't even mention the other New Yorker
on the ticket. I mean there is, there is a
way in which our selves are not just these
individual things. They're all about forming
these social connections.
I have to ask you at this point, as an empirical
philosopher, do you test these things using
brain images or using some other kind of empirical
data?
We mostly use other kinds of empirical data.
So where we're asking people questions, we're
looking at -right now we're looking at parole
decisions. So, why do you let somebody off
from a prison sentence? Maybe it's because
their behavior has changed. Maybe it's because
a lot of time has passed and you think they've
suffered enough already in prison. But maybe
it's because you think their values have changed
and they're no longer the same person. You've
actually kept somebody in prison who didn't
commit the crime.
So your idea about who their self really is
just suddenly changed or you heard about who
they're going to- what they did or what they
didn't do or that they- you know, judges are
making decisions about what the self, the
other self is. That's right. Or a conversation
about who to vote for. Suddenly you switch.
The other self is evil.
Well that there is a lot of that kind of judgment.
So one of the reasons why we worry so much
about moral change is- is there is this anxiety
that somebody who we cared about we felt close
to, who we trusted, is now on the other side.
So forgive me for asking this, but it sounds
to me like you're describing a basic dynamic
of human history and it's horrendous cycle
of war and more war.
I think one of the one of the really important
discoveries at social psychology- wasn't a
discovery, we've known it through human history-
but one of the things that we've been able
to measure is how people form groups. And
old results dating back decades of what's
called the minimal group of facts and you
can just arbitrarily assign people to any
group, they form strong allegiance with anyone
who's in the same group, and hostility towards
others. Morality is the ultimate of group
membership.
And these findings are universal for the human
species wherever we are on the planet.
I-you know, as somebody who really is interested
in culture, I'm really interested in how human
minds are shaped by experience. Values are
created through history, created through the
cauldron of culture. To that extent, I'm-
I'm reluctant to speak too much in universals.
I would like to hope that we can find ways
of getting along and forming affiliations
with people whose values differ dramatically
from ours. But it certainly has been the case
that this fault line has led to a tremendous
amount of conflict and violence in human history
right.
Martha, I see you nodding again. Which suggests
something you might disagree with.
No, no, no. That's- how interesting, nod.
So- so. While we stay on the subject of self,
you've done-you have an experiment of some
kind that you've- you've done some study with
regard to political identity?
Well, we've done a lot of studies showing
that what people consider most important for
identity is their moral values, including
their political values. And then it occurred
to us that this really serves a function and
the function is forming social alliances.
So it's not only important to you that you
vote a certain way. It's important that others
know this about you. So how do we signal that?
How do we make sure that everyone I meet casually,
no matter how quickly, has a pretty good chance
of guessing correctly about what my moral
values are. So for instance if you drive a
pickup truck, are you more likely to be a
Republican or a Democrat? If you drive a foreign
car-
Are you asking me?
Well I- ask yourselves, you know. If you drive
a foreign car, more likely to be a Republican
or Democrat? If you, say, eat sushi, more
likely to be a Republican or Democrat? If
you like red meat, if you read military history,
if you like NASCAR racing and what do these
things have to do with morality? NASCAR racing?
But, we can guess that in NASCAR enthusiasts
is more likely to be conservative than liberal.
Why? And the reason is, all of these aspects
of human taste are signaling, they're trying
to communicate to others what sort of group
we belong to.
So you're saying that one's enthusiasms or
groups you join have a big element in them
of which group do I want to identify with
and signal thereby to others for a warm fuzzy
group feeling and an antagonistic feeling.
You have some, I believe some pictures to
give us a taste here?
Yeah so we got interested. Can you tell by
looking, whether somebody is a Democrat or
Republican? So. We elected dozens and dozens
of faces. We use an arbitrary method of generating
a big picture set of faces and we don't even
know the political party that these people
belong to. So it's all it's all just whether
people have an opinion about it. And we found
overwhelmingly that people do. So we can take
a look at some examples and
Should we bring up the house lights?
Yeah let's let's have a let's have a look.
So. Now what you're going to do now is you're
going to vote. You're going to vote by show
of hands.
So this person isn't wearing any political
buttons or any- any kind of paraphernalia
that would tell you. How many of you think
this is a Republican raise your hands. How
many of you think this is a Democrat? So why?
You know that's really weird.
Let's look at another example. OK. So in some
cases maybe- maybe. Let's see how this one
goes. How many think this is a Republican?
How many say Democrat? OK. So still big, big,
big majority. Next one. OK.
So what do we have here. How many you say
Republican in this case? OK the house goes
up. And Democrat anyone? So yes, I mean, obviously
we know we all know counter-examples. We all
know people who spent their- their- put their
lives on the line for this country working
for military causes, even though they vote
for the Democratic Party, that's not unheard
of. But the fact that we can signal this in
some way, is an indication that- the fact
we have such consensus on these opinions shows
how important this is in social decision making.
Let's look at another case.
OK how many say Republican? How can say Democrat?
Wow. So overwhelming. It's just that she's
wearing black. Right? We're trying to figure
out what drives these decisions. Let's look
at one more example and you'll get a kind
of complete. For this. OK how many say Republican
here? OK so here we got the majority. Anyone
want to say Democrat here? A few. And I think
there's one more. OK so how many say Republican?
How many say Democrat? So very very- for those
of you who have not been able to see the hands
go up- we're probably- if we measure this
room, we'd probably be in the 90s percentile
in terms of agreement on which one is a Republican
and which one is a Democrat. Sometimes it's
ethnicity, sometimes it's occupation, like
the military commitment. But what about the
beard? What about the black hat? The fact
that randomly chosen people on the street
are conveying to others what party they belong
to, I think is one of the most revealing things
I've encountered in my investigations about
the self. How many think I'm a Republican?
This raises a lot of questions to me. Why
are you applauding?
What are you applauding for?
Why were you so amused that you laughed at
each one of his questions? I mean this is
a very serious question. What was so amusing
about this. I've got other questions such
as if you showed these pictures to somebody
in a different time in a different century.
Very important.
Even if they didn't have- they might have
looked conservative for some people, whatever
that means. So in other words, you're also
showing us if this empirical data is building
up some of the understandings of some of the
ugly sides of human nature or parts of it,
such as stereotypes and judgmental-I mean
this is talking about the basis of our judgment.
Martha? Once again, you're nodding a lot.
That's my striatum, right? I have to reprogram
my striatum. Get out of that habit.
No but I mean- you also definitely- you were.
Oh since you are probing, I'll say that I
thought the most-I think there is- what's
in one of the interesting things, if I may,
is I'm outside of my neuroscience area of
expertise here, was that I think people were
laughing because we all recognize it's silly
to reach these conclusions, at least in part.
But I actually think that Jesse's last comment
was the most interesting one. The point is
not that we have strong opinions about this.
We know that people use stereotypes and all
kinds of ways. I think the point is that all
of us use- take advantage of those cues in
our choices every day. So it's a social projection
of that, which I thought was actually directly
related to what Joy was saying about how we
communicate nonverbally and verbally and in
that way because we're soliciting -are- people
like us to know- we're signaling to them.
So you three brain scientists who actually
look at the gray matter in the purple and
green and dark matters and white matters.
Find something to talk about with this philosopher
that may be able to match your scientific
data from your brain labs with the type of
data that he's turning up from these. Could
you explain the connection there?
Let me just say little bit that. I think that
one of the things that fascinates me the most
about what you're talking about, is what it
tells us about our brains and how actively
we interrogate and seek information about
others and how we relate that to ourselves.
It's as if in that seeking process, we become
unified in some way with who with the other
and I think that's the next stage of neuroscience
is going to tell us a lot more about those
very fundamental mechanisms. And one of my
goals in neuroscience is to move this most
fascinating idea from the hands of philosophers
and put it- well maybe- maybe empirical philosophers
are different, and but put it in the hands
of neuroscience so that we can understand
the neural machinery, the neural mechanisms
that drive this connection that we have with
other people and how it is we interrogate
other people to understand who they are.
If I can if I can quickly come to the defense.
Well I mean I really look forward to that
day and I think the stuff you're doing with
really the kinds of methods that can study
social interaction with brain imaging are
extremely exciting. One of the problems that
I've had with neuroscience, as a field, given
its current technologies, is it really misses
out on the social. We have in this culture,
biophilia. We think that if something is biologically
explained, it's real and if it's cultural
or about ideas or even about the social, it's
somehow less real. So we have for instance,
if you look at- the National Institute of
Health funds studies on addiction, like alcoholism.
Overwhelmingly, that money goes to studies
looking at genes and brain circuits, right?
It's looking at those factors. But we know
that sociogenic factors, factors about where
you live, factors about poverty, which Martha
studied. All of those things are at least
maybe more important studies of genetic relatedness
show that if you're an alcoholic, there there's
about a 15 percent chance that your offspring
will be alcoholics. That means the overwhelming
majority of them are not. Those studies, if
they're done with adoption, the effects are
tiny, often go away, or very- very inconsistent
across studies. If they're done cross-culturally,
the numbers begin to look ridiculous. So America
has about a 5 percent alcoholism rate. Russia
is about 16 percent. Islamic countries are
mostly under 1 percent. So we can have a 16
times increase in whether you become an alcoholic
if you're born in Russia as opposed to in
Iran.
And you're looking forward to the time when
the neurological brain scientists can- can
connect why these things happen.
That's the future I'm excited about, bringing
culture into the brain, showing how the circuits
of the brain are playing a role in taking
that cultural information and driving behavior
with them.
This is not what the neuroscientists, or one
of them is supposed to say, but I'll say it
anyway. Which is yes, I would like very much
for us to understand this at a neural level,
and many of us would, but I think maybe I'd
kind of back up Jesse's point and say it even
more strongly, which is there are many societal
questions about behavior that we know that
that behavior emerges from the brain, because
it's not coming from anywhere else. But when
understanding the brain doesn't necessarily
help us treat that behavior. And there's a
lot of other information that's necessary
and so I argue that for things like understanding
"is there a self? What is a self? What does
this have to do with how we socialize.?" And
any questions at that level, the complex questions
about what it means to human. We're never
going to understand them only in terms of
neurons. Maybe not never. Maybe one day. But
when that day gets closer, it will be the
psychologists and the philosophers who have
set us up to start thinking about those questions
in intelligent ways. Just saying that something
happens in the brain in of itself doesn't
tell us how it happens.
It's neutral it doesn't have morality connected
to it. And also, the more you guys have talked
about learning about the brain, the more potential
dangers of hacking into the brain, of misusing
this information. The old human problem, learning
things that, I mean, you could learn how to
control minds or you could do DNA.
So Martha's done some thought in depth about
these issues of sort of the ethics of neuroscience.
Ethics.
That's right.
Yeah, well.
How do you apply them?
You know to understand a system, to thoroughly
understand a system is to be able to control
it. Right? To predict it and even potentially
to control it. And, you know, you can you
can rest easy tonight knowing that we neuroscientists
are still pretty clueless about how this incredibly
complex system works, you know. But, we are
learning something. I mean, I think the things
that you've heard from Joy and Daphna, you
know, show that neuroscience is beginning
to get a handle on some of these things. You
know, there's a lot of ways to manipulate
brain function. Drugs is sort of the time
honored way you sort of tweak, you know, the
neurochemistry. But people are now using brain
stimulation to do that. Even noninvasive brain
stimulation, which sounds almost like an oxymoron,
right? Like how can you stimulate the brain
but not open up the body? Except that you
can do that with electrical fields and magnetic
fields. And there's a lot of research now
and a lot of actual just people doing it.
You can go online and buy devices that will
electrically stimulate your brain from outside
of your head. And so that's, you know,- now
that's people doing it for themselves. But
you could imagine going back to your judges
sentencing people. You know, you could imagine
a sort of well-meaning policy saying, "We're
not going to just lock you up. We're going
to actually try to rehabilitate you." We just
need to sort of, you know, regulate your,
you know, left dorsolateral prefrontal cortex.
And- so we're going to just, you know, put
an electrode there.
Indeed, and sometimes it's good- people who
buy full spectrum light to look at it in the
morning to beat the winter depression that-
there's all kinds of good benefits here. But,
Yes.
It could be abused.
Yeah. I mean you have to ask like who has
the right to, you know, who's brain is it
anyway? Kind of like who has the right to-
And now we're going to get back to self here,
but this is already reminding me of that-
this is a beautiful peaceful conversation
about something that is not always so peaceful,
I gather in the academic world. What is it
called? What is it? Neuro-Skepticism? I've-
I've shown the books of some neuroscientists
to some psychologists who are very thoughtful
people who say, well this person knows enough
about the brain to be dangerous and maybe
someday. But these neurologists think they
can control things and they can't. You all
are nodding. You're aware that this these
fights are going on, right?
Indeed. In fact I think that the term is called
NeuroBollocks.
NeuroBollocks?
NeuroBollocks is a very popular term that
is in a way a way of trashing neuroscience
and the notion that we can learn about ourselves.
I could see how a psychiatrist and shrinks
would be threatened by you guys, because they've-
they've figured out they have to just talk
to a patient about some event in the past
and get them to just talk. And they fear that
you all are going to come in and say no, no.
But I'm not representing it correctly.
I don't think it's fair to reduce it to insecurity
or threat. I think there's sometimes as a
society, we get so carried away and how exciting
this all is and it's potential down the road
that there is a feeling that we're already
there. When in truth, it's a very young field,
understanding complex psychological mental
phenomena is really it's early stages. Right,
right that's where we started by saying- not
long ago we thought some of this was in the
heart. So we know it's in the brain and we
know where in the brain. Between that and
understanding the how of how these things
happen, there's a long way and I think a lot
of the Neuro-Skepticism, both outside but
also within the field, is really a healthy
sign of a growing field. Sort of like in its
adolescence, maybe, rather than its infancy,
where there's a lot of rebellion. Which I
think it's healthy for advancing the science.
Right. You're reminding me of an ancient-
was it the Egyptians or I forget who- used
to think that thought and reason happened
not here, but in the liver and that the soul
was based in the liver. They hadn't quite
figured it out yet. You all of you got a different
idea about it, but perhaps you're connecting
some of these things. Because the conversation
we're having in the greenroom about next year
was about how actually it's all the little
microbes inside of us that are really controlling
us, using us just to walk them around. So
we have to study the minds and the brains
of the neuro- of the microbes. But that's
it. That's next year. I mean.
I just want to come on the point that the
anxiety about neuroscience is connected to
brain control. I think we also need to remember
that behavior is more typically, and quite
powerfully, controlled by social forces. So
you know, many of my family members were killed
in the Holocaust. Had they been of a different
creed, they would have been the perpetrators,
not the victims. And I think we all need to
remember- so you are guessed my political
orientation, maybe not correctly maybe correctly,
I won't say. But I will say I was born and
raised in New York City and had I been born
and raised upstate or in the Midwest or in
the South where I've also lived, I might vote
for the other party. And so it's very important
to remember that human behavior is dramatically
affected by things without direct biological
intervention. Right now we're so far away
technologically from changing behavior by
altering brain circuits that we should be
much more worried about the social forces
than the biological.
And you raise a great hope here, which is
that if general acceptance among the world's
scientists, and philosophers, and economists,
and psychologists of some of these basic patterns
that are true of all humans, then we see horrendous
behavior that could lead to great damage,
such as storm troopers marching in perfect
unison. We could possibly, on the new web
world, this new global brain or global mind,
if we can talk about it in those terms. Spread
the knowledge that, look folks, this is a
known disease. Let's all get together and
be open about it and stop it before it happens.
That's very optimistic. But why not, right?
That's not impossible. A reasonable hope.
I think though-again, the biophilia is at
work here, because when we start to think
about the bad things in the world as a disease
on the model, it's some sort of biological
anomaly, we focus on interventions that are
at that level. But most of it- so take violence.
There's a lot of work on criminal genes, or
people born bad, and maybe there is some variation
in tendency toward aggressive behavior that
has a base in biology. But the effect size
of social causes, like poverty, which Martha
has worked on- and I want to say this is that
an extraordinary panel, because all of the
neuroscientist on this panel study things,
like anorexia nervosa or poverty, that are
social factors that show that the brain is
not fixed but is constantly changing and adapting
to the social setting. If you want to change
things like the violence that exists in the
world, we need to not be thinking about the
cure at the biological level, but at the biosocial.
And the scientists- and all of you seem to
be telling us more and more that you keep
discovering that the brain is much more flexible
than anybody imagined. There was a headline
recently that said that they've discovered
that there is one organ in the body that has
a different DNA in it- in the same organ you
have a lot of different DNA in the cells.
The brain. So that your DNA is not-it is not
the DNA in every brain cell but- in other
words, there is there's all kinds of ways
evolution has taught our bodies apparently
to take advantage of as much flexibility as
possible to adapt to what's needed. So to
get back to our central promise, to figure
out what about the self and- and what we think
about the self, and consciousness, we have
a quote from Thomas Huxley, who is a biologist
who, if I'm not mistaken, is the fellow who
advertised how interesting Darwin was. "How
it is that anything so remarkable as a state
of consciousness comes about by irritating
nervous tissue is just as unaccountable as
the appearance of the Genie when Aladdin rubbed
his lamp." Do you three brain scientists think
that still pertains? It still is unaccountable
are you beginning to account for it?
Well I don't think I'm going to shift to studying
lamps.
For the state of consciousness. I guess the
question would be for him- what did he think
he meant by state of consciousness?
I mean I think this gets us back again to
this question of subjectivity versus objectivity,
which I know sounds like dialogue from an
old Woody Allen film and Diane Keaton says,
"Yes, but subjectivity of objectivity." You
know. If. If what he means by state of consciousness,
is basically the focus of your attention,
then I think it's wrong. What he's saying.
I think we have certainly in sort of a broad
sketch of, if not a detailed account, of the
way in which the neural networks of our brain
can kind of sift and select for certain subsets
of the information impinging on your senses.
Focus on certain memories that you've encoded
in the past that you become "conscious" of
in the sense of aware or attending to. But,
I think what he's probably talking about,
is that people usually at some point in your
childhood, you've puzzled over the following
question: What if what I see when I look at
something that I call red is- looks to you
like what I see is what I would call green.
Right? Does this? I can't even see people
up there, but, you know, it is kind of amusing
that, you know, when we're 10 years old and
we're all philosophers and. So that difference
between the experience of red and the experience
of green, which you can never sort out just
by talking to somebody, right? Because I say,
"Well does it look red to you?" And you say,
"Of course it looks red." Because all your
life, you've called that, to me green color,
red. Right? OK. It's- it's that difference
between the experience of red and green. OK.
That completely subjective experience that
I don't think we have a clue how that results
from the material world.
So the first I think most people thought of
this problem. But for the first time, I'm
beginning to realize that you guys may be
on the beginning of a track that could one
day figure out how to do that to get into
the brain to get an image out and matches
against spectra, or something. But I don't
know. I mean is the subject of prison is really,
really hard to break out of.
The subjective prison, and that's a great,
yeah. And I think even if you started poking
around with micro electrodes and recording
the activity of neurons you still would- I
mean you'd say, "OK that -so that's firing
action potentials now. What does that look
like to you? And you'd say red. But it's the
same problem. You know, so that, I think,
we're never going to get at.
Never? Never
Well, ok. Never say never. You know I read
a really interesting article recently, I think
it was the New York Review of Books, by a
philosopher named Galen Strawson. And basically,
he had a really interesting take on the mind-
body problem. He just turned it on its head
and said you know what, consciousness isn't
mysterious, what's mysterious is the physical
world. So like we- we, you know. He says,
and I think yes- there's something to be said
for this- we don't really understand the physical
world. And that's why we don't see how consciousness
can emerge from it. And you know, he points
to the fact that quantum physics is really
weird and you know, I think it was-Feynman
said you know, "If you really understand quantum
physics, then you are totally confused by
it." Or something to that effect, right? ,,So.
Yeah. So I think I I don't think our humble
human brains wonderful as they are, well adapted
as they are to all the things that we have
to do in life, from like negotiate the physical
world, to use language to develop social relationships.
I don't-I think they can do a lot of great
things, but I don't think they're ever going
to understand how consciousness in that red
-green sense emerges from networks of neurons.
Very quickly before we get to Q&A, we just
have 10 minutes left to go to questions from
around the planet. Talk about a new planet
consciousness. Because we have them on our
iPad here from people who've been watching
live all over the planet and in this auditorium.
Of the three of you who have not just been
talking, do you all agree with what she just
said in general about the permanence of the
subject at present?
Or you have -or do you doubt it? Or, Joy?
Or do you know- know?
Well, the most truthful answer is of course
that I don't know. I mean, this is clearly
what's been called the "hard problem" in in
neuroscience and the "hard problem" is how
does my subjectivity compare with yours? I-
I like the gravity comment that-and it is
related to your notion that what consciousness
really isn't as important to understand as
the outside world and that is, how we perceive
the outside world and how we perceive others
is perhaps the hallmark that we're interested
in. You know, when in science, when we when
we take on a problem, like say we want to
understand consciousness, usually we have
an idea of what the answer looks like. And
I think that that's part of our problem here.
If consciousness stared us in the face, would
we know it? Would we know if we really have
the right answer?
If there is it- there
And I'm not sure we would. And so and so I
think that maybe studying that the physical
world might be a faster route to consciousness
and maybe someday consciousness to come knocking
on our door and some data will say to us,
"Hey I'm consciousness. You've missed me all
along."
I'm a little more optimistic.
Are you? Okay.
Yeah, I think we might change. You know, we
when we find the answer, it might be because
we've changed the question a little. But I
think, you know, yes we're in the infancy,
there a lot of things we don't know. But the
progress has been amazing. At the same time,
I think I think there's reason to think we'll
understand a great deal about the subjective.
I really want to echo that. I think it's actually
an easy problem in the following sense. Of
all the things we've studied biologically,
this is one where we're really getting very
close to being able to say this is the exact
process that makes the difference between
being conscious and not. We also understand
why studying that process doesn't fully feel
explanatorily satisfying. So we have stories
about that too. But the main thing is if you
want to know which are the mechanisms of consciousness
in the brain, we're pretty close to an answer.
If you ask, how does culture affect the brain?
How do you cure racism in the brain? Those
are things we don't know. Those are really
hard problems. They're big complex multifaceted
problems. I think we should stop worrying
about consciousness maybe and turn attention
to those.
And when we asked the question, "Can you define
consciousness, we're asking for a verbal answer
to a verbal problem, but there may not be
a problem- it may just be one of the basics
of the universe. All right. So we're going
to take- we're going to go over by about four
minutes. You really only have 6 minutes left
and I want to take 10 minutes to answer questions
from around the planet to expand our sense
of self in some way. Here's a question from,
I don't know where on the planet. If there
was an exact clone of someone with the exact
same brain, would they still have the same
mind? Would they be the same self? I think
I know the answer.
Bill, why don't you tell us?
I'm just a journalist. If there was an exact
clone of someone with the exact same brain,
would they still have the same mind? Would
they be the same self? For no more than a
nanosecond. I think the answer from what you
will have said is no. They wouldn't be the
same self, if they were two different people.
They're in different places, they're experiencing-
is that- am I right
I was going to say something similar, but
it depends I mean what they mean by the question.
Do they have the exact same experiences? A
full replication of the brain with its memories
and identical experiences up to that moment,
then yeah
Yeah, same- same brain means you know, same
traces of experiences embedded.
Right. Yeah exactly. You know, in that case
I'd say that
But for a moment, but very soon they're in
two different places, they're not getting
exactly-
Right, you put them into different rooms,
and it's no longer the same brain, I guess.
Unless you feed them by artificial means.
The same virtual reality, or something.
I think I'm the least philosophical person
on this panel.
Well there's a wonderful science fiction novel
that has a lot of fun with exactly that pre-text
called Mindscan by Robert J Sawyer.
All right. Well so here's another question
from somewhere on the planet. I don't know
anything about the person. I presume it's
a human. Can't be sure these days. Is the
rise in digital communication affecting our
signaling to others? Have some of you done
work on this?
I just want to jump in on this question because
a lot of what I do, in addition to memories
about learning and I get questioned- I also
have a kid-kids at a particular age where
a lot of other parents ask me you know, in
panic ,is it true that my kids using their
iPads is changing their brains? And the answer
is obviously yes, because everything we do
is changing our brains. So.
What about-do you know if it's bad, if it's
changing it in a bad or diminishing away.
You know I think that we don't know but that's
because it's very hard to know for anything.
And Jesse earlier before this panel gave a
great example of addiction. Right that addiction
can be seen in a particular context is really
bad undesirable thing but if somebody chooses
to pursue it or drug use I should say for
any particular reason it might be a goal in
of itself. So I think one of the interesting
things, we don't have a whole lot time to
elaborate a whole lot on, is that there are
these- the- the neural perspective is not
about judging the behaviors that emerge. It's
about understanding what happens in the brain
to support that. A lot of things you can look
at.
I mean, we haven't even begun to ask whether
what you're- what you're studying can begin
to explain to us whatever the word "intelligent"
might mean. You're all nodding. In other words,
that's a big question. From around the world
from someone on Twitter, somewhere, I would
like the panel to talk about what neuroscience
has to say about determinism and free will
and how that relates to the self. The old
free will question. And how does that relate
to the question? What does neuroscience have
to say about any of this?
It's a whole panel.
I mean in so far as, the claim that, you know,
all of our behavior is determined by the brain.
You know, insofar as the brain is a deterministic
physical system, then yeah, the neuroscience
view of people is a view that our behavior
is all determined and therefore, free will
makes no sense.
That we are all what?
Free will makes no sense. I mean-
Free will makes no sense?
Yeah. I mean, you know, don't shoot the messenger.
I'm just saying that, you know. I'm just saying
that of-
So the presidential vote that's coming up
makes no sense. There's no free will involved?
We're just billiard balls bouncing around
on a table. And, you know.
I'm- I'm sorry, you're smiling and I just
can't accept this because I can't accept it.
Myself doesn't like this idea.
So subjectively it doesn't- subjectively what
Martha's saying doesn't make sense doesn't
make sense. We have choice.
So all three of you neuroscientists who look
into the brain all day, Joy, free will make
sense to you?
Well, I don't I'm not I don't have any data
in my head that speaks to free will. As an
individual, I like to think that I'm in control,
but I'm not sure that the data that I have
as a neuroscientist as- answers one way or
the other
And the microbes that we're being used to
walk them around may, in fact, be in charge.
Yeah that's right. That's right.
I mean, I think the free will debate is another
one where we've gotten very obsessed with
this, and maybe it's a kind of Western individual
obsession, we're obsessed with this total
control. Can I determine my behavior? I think
the anxiety that we don't have free will is
based on a false pretext and the pretext is
that without free will we can't hold people
responsible. Without free will we can't change.
Those are fundamentally false claims.
That's interesting. You mean, in other words,
what really matters is is can we figure out
what's good and healthy and compassionate,
maybe.
Well, also what do we do when somebody does
something wrong? Are they- should be- should
we hold them responsible? And also, who should
be held responsible? Is it just that body,
that person, that organism that did this thing?
Or is it also the social conditions that led
to that behavior? Giving up on free will allows
us to see how responsibility is sometimes
distributed across broader groups. And that's
an effective tool not for being stuck and
fixed in human behavior, but an effective
tool for change. By studying how behavior
is controlled, we can better understand human
potential, human flexibility.
Something kind of- and indeed, I wish Thomas
Jefferson was here right now because we assume
that endowed by the maker that all people
are- have life, liberty, and the pursuit of
happiness. Is that required or-does it not
require free will?
I think, I mean, there's a long answer to
that question. But the short answer that question
is : if we do set out a series of ideals What
is it to live a good life? We have things
like positive psychology that study human
learning, human well being. To achieve that
isn't about having freedom in the sense of
this metaphysical ability to control your
fate. It's about social capacity to create
a form of governance that allows humans to
live better than they're currently living.
And we're pretty far from those goals.
We are. But the new neural net may help us.
The Web world may help us get closer to them.
And this comes very close to something that's
central. Compassion. In the end it's possibly
always about, at the very least, survival.
Because we know this kind of behavior with
compassion helps us survive as a species.
Because we don't suffer a lot and die a lot
and concentrate on bad things and feel like
not wanting to live. So there may be some
survival advantage. God's Darwinian tautology,
you might call it, for us to see that life
is good and go on, we have to throw out how
to be compassionate and want to go on living.
Which is not unrelated to this question asked
from Twitter, somewhere on the planet, "Can
you talk about what parts of the brain are
activated while experiencing compassion and
experiencing a sense of mor-morality? Are
brain scientist- would like to take- what
parts of the brain are activated while experiencing
compassion and experiencing a sense of morality?
I think if that person were-I would return
that question with a question. So there have
been studies that have done sort of brain
mapping of social cognition when you're thinking
about others, when you're judging others,
when you're experiencing positive feelings
versus negative feelings that point to particular
regions. But I think what I want to do is,
really ask the question in return and say,
"Why is it important to understand those regions
particularly? And I think the reason is, you
know, that what's driving that question is
this idea, I think, that if we understand
where something happens we understand how
it works. And I think that's a really good
first pass. That's kind of where we were 10
years ago. But I think what we really want
to understand is what else are those areas
doing? What do those neurons do? What are
they connecting with? Because that same map
that, one would see in the brain for compassion,
social cognition, overlaps often with goal
pursuit and other kinds of functions. I think
one of the fundamental things to keep in mind
when we think about brain mapping is that
it's not- one part of the brain never does
one function there's not a compassion center
in the brain.
Wow. It means, you know, I've heard all that
for the whole time- as you're finding that
any one part of the brain does a bunch of
things. It's connected to a lot of other things.
Right. I mean-
It's multitasking.
There is specialization, absolutely. But it's
not specialization that necessarily maps are
terms.
So the part of the brain doesn't solve the
problem. It's the connections between that
part of the brain an other parts of the brain.
I want to back Daphna up on this with the
additional comment that I think one of the
things is really interesting here is the study
of individual differences. Certainly with
respect to a trait like compassion or empathy,
for example, we all differ a great deal. Some
people are very compassionate and very empathetic
and others not so much. And so one of the
things that's very difficult to explain from
questions like, "What part of the brain does
this?" is why are we so different? And the
nuances that sort of lead to our- our individual
selves I think is part of that part of the
answer here that yes, there are certain major
systems of the brain that are engaged when
we're empathetic or compassionate, but it's
executed in many different ways, in many different
brains, in many different times and that's
where the fascination is partly
You all are giving me the feeling- you're
just at the beginning of a whole new world.
The doors are opening up. One last question
for all the world and we're out of time. But
don't worry, our panelists will be available
in the lobby for a few minutes to ask a few
more questions from. This is from Twitter.
Don't know what continent or or or boat or
plane this question comes from. What is the
connection between illness like PTSD and the
experience of memory and consciousness? Can
you can your brain be then rewired?
It, I'll jump in on the memory angle as someone
else wants to- again could be a whole, kind
of, hour long conversation. A very short answer
is that that's something we understand some
things about and people with a smaller hippocampus,
we mentioned, have a greater propensity for
PTSD. And in some preliminary experimental
work, people have shown that you can exploit
the fact that memories change to start to
rewire traumatic memory.
And you can see that in the brain.
Nothing clinical yet.
Your neuroimaging- and you can see this effect.
There has been a- most of the important work
was developed in animals with pharmacology
and people like Liz Phelps, who's here at
NYU, have used that approach to try to create
a very simplified model of creating a negative
memory and then rewriting it by figuring out
what the parameters are. How we can rewire
within how within how much time of when the
memory was created and so forth. But it's
definitely related to the hippocampal wiring.
Sounds like a positive and helpful answer.
So quick question for each of you and we're
done fulfilling the promise of our title.
Your quick short definition, if you have one
if you don't, don't be ashamed to say it,
of self.
I am my values. The self the self is the set
of our deeply held values.
The self is the set of deeply held values.
Yes, the values that connect us to to others
who are like minded.
Wow.
I'm not sure there is a self in the way we've
been talking about it. I'll just leave it
there.
Question, Is it a verb or a noun? Is self
a verb or a noun?
You know, if if by self, we mean something
that does endure over time, some essence of
a person that makes them the same person.
I'm kind of with David Hume, I guess, and
Buddhists and various others. I'm not sure
there is such a thing. Although I admit, that
we certainly have the intuition that there
is.
That there is, right. A part of the subjective
prison, perhaps. Daphna?
I'd say, you know, that the self is- we are
what we've learned from our world and what
we remember from our experiences. But with
the, with the specification that that's reflected
more in what we actually do that defines who
we are rather than what we're- what we- who
we think we are.
More towards verbal or?
Action.
Action. Joy?
I'd like to turn the question upside down.
And think of myself as what other people think
of me.
Oh. Something to think about. Well, in three
or four minutes the most of these good folks
will be in the lobby to answer a few more
questions. I think there's nothing but- not
a blown mind, but a blossoming mind. Thank
you very much.